i tweeted one today that i the other day
that i like which is a lot of founders
are really proud of their organic growth
rates and they're like hey look how
great we're growing our cac is zero and
we're growing this fast and for me
that's actually like a red flag because
paid acquisition and sales marketing
understanding your channels
is a muscle you have to start doing it
and iterating on it and learning and you
do it and you realize something's not
white and you get better at it and
showing that you basically very early on
in the sort of life cycle of your
business
realize that this is the muscle that
needs to get big and strong for your
business to get as big as it could get
and starting to build it and starting to
think about it and starting to get good
at it is like super duper critical
and i think there's a lot of sort of
examples in businesses like this in
every aspect where
being proud that you don't do something
that you eventually will have to do i
think is for me it's a red flag i'm like
oh you mean you haven't started learning
how to do this yet that means it's going
to be painful when the time comes
yeah and really it is when you think
about marketing as a muscle you can go
through 10 campaigns and
really achieve very little and then all
of a sudden you get you figure out some
audience or some new channel or some new
creative
and it just goes 10x and all of a sudden
your cat goes from 100 to 10 and you're
like oh there it is
so it's pretty humbling like how
difficult it is to actually get to the
point where you make something that
actually breaks out so you definitely
want to stick with it and yeah i think
that is a bit of a tell i i would say
low product velocity i find super
annoying and i also find super annoying
people who
obsess over things that are not
uh critical to the business i have one
founder who is obsessing over the super
voting shares and you know i'm like this
you don't even have product market fit
and we're talking about super voting
shares what what's going on here let's
get product market fit and then talk
about that uh or like they were
concerned about their board conversion
i'm not saying that's not an important
thing but i was like you don't even have
a thriving business here and we're like
debating stuff that's not important then
other times that people say hey yeah
we're gonna get this done we'll get that
done and they just don't get it done
and i'm just like you know what there's
no plan here and the the cadence is too
slow you have to move fast with a sense
of urgency and i've just watched people
meander and meander and i'm just like
where's the sense of urgency here just
pick a date that the new product comes
out and tell the team version two is
coming out october 1st the end and if it
doesn't come out october 1st you're all
fired and we're starting over we have to
put your foot down and say we're going
to be competitive in the marketplace and
some people do this really aggressively
and it has great success and listen it
might burn some people out it might rub
some people the wrong way trigger
warning if you don't intense work
environments startups are not for you
but man have a sense of urgency i think
that's one of the big reasons why tech
and the media and this world crowd are
having this you know big battle is
because
startups are about going fast with a
sense of urgency
and then socialism communism and
work-life balance and living a full 360
life where you're
focused on you and your self-care is
diametrically opposed to trying to beat
competitors and to trying to act with a
sense of urgency and so one neither side
can understand the other side if you
don't want to be an intense environment
it could work for the post office go
work for starbucks go work for any
number of jobs where you're not creating
any new things you're just punching a
clock or creating a delightful product
day in and day out but you're not trying
to change the world that's fine but if
you're at a startup with a clock ticking
and you're running out of company cash
you have to move fast people you cannot
dilly dally
speed is success and going slow equals
death you will get caught the zombies
will catch you they'll overwhelm you and
you will be ripped to shreds and they
will eat the flesh off your bones you
need to beat out the other people sorry
to say it so graphically but it's just
how annoying is it when you invest in a
company and they just turn into the post
office
and they're like yeah we're not working
this weekend yeah i don't know if we're
going to get that done does that happen
often to you or not no thank god i mean
that doesn't happen that often but
it does happen
yeah that's a huge filter for me it's
like
the speed of execution is everything in
startup life if you're slow you're dead
in business it's important to be
memorable and sending gifts is a classy
way to create a great memory but
gifting's tough it can take forever or
you get sent to the wrong location and
it's never scaled properly until now
snack magic is a stress-free easy and
customizable way to delight employees or
customers snack magic uses software to
help recipients build their own snack
box and we're using it now for our
gifting you click on the link it says
hey jason or this week in startups you
have this 50 100 250 credit what would
you like and then you start going
through all these amazing snacks and you
get this incredible gift box see here
and i love a bunch of different types of
gourmet items i'll take out a couple of
them you're gonna hear some crinkling
right now you can get these air dried
veggies and i'm trying to eat more
vegetables and this seemed like a
reasonable snack for me we would have
these back and forth discussions of what
to get our customers and what they like
it's like oh they don't eat chocolate oh
they don't like cheese oh this person's
keto this person's that this person's
vegan just send somebody this snack
magic link and you're done and they get
what they want whether you want to
delight one person or a thousand snack
magic makes it easy send it to an
employer right now say thanks for the
hard work here's a hyundai here's 100
bucks and you can get 10 off if you use
my offer code twist by going to snack
magic dot com slash twist very simple
snack magic dot com slash twist 10 off
okay let's get back to this amazing
episode